[Música]
tradicionalmente cada 9 de mayo tanto
ucrania como rusia celebran el
aniversario de la victoria sobre la
alemania nazi en la segunda guerra
mundial pero este año el ánimo es muy
distinto por la ofensiva rusa en ucrania
el presidente de rusia vladimir putin
dijo que las tropas rusas y las milicias
de danny shittu camps luchan por su
patria y también para que nadie olvide
las lecciones de la segunda guerra
mundial y es que bajo esa premisa de
desclasificar a ucrania moscú entonces
inició la invasión contra su vecino del
lado del otro lado el presidente de
ucrania volodymyr zielinski afirmó que
su país ahora tendrá dos días de la
victoria con el eventual triunfo de su
ejército sobre el ruso para ello
entonces quiero saludar a nuestro
segundo invitado del día el es la diosa
y analista de relaciones internacionales
y estudios estratégicos de las fuerzas
terrestres navales aéreas y espaciales
rusas gracias por estar con nosotros los
doctor labios es un gusto para nosotros
que estés aquí en directo américa de
france 24 de preguntó cómo se puede leer
entonces este particular día de la
victoria con todo el contexto de guerra
buenos días y bueno está claro que putin
no logró en militarmente en ucrania lo
que se dice que había pretendido al
invadir el 24 de febrero pasado y que
habría sido copar a todo el país de
ucrania y pues tener tenerlo dominado
incluso en unos días ni siquiera en una
semana pero no fue así entonces como
saben todos es de la fase inicial de
tratar de capturar kiev la capital en el
norte noroeste de ucrania pues se
concentró en tratar de capturar el este
de ucrania la región del donbass sobre
todo estratégicamente muy rica
importante en el carbón petróleo de
perdón gas de esquisto agrícola en
agricultura también el perno ha logrado
se ha estancado su campaña en su nueva
fase de esa ofensiva de su invasión en
el este entonces algo tenía que decir
pero claro lo que es propaganda y es
mentira y porque bueno no olvidemos que
cuando invadió el 24 de febrero pues sí
como ustedes han dicho dijo que era para
tumbar el régimen nazi unión así que hay
en ucrania totalmente falso porque
recuerdo a la audiencia el presidente
selenski volodymyr selenski judíos con
familiares que murieron en el holocausto
durante la segunda guerra mundial
entonces bueno aparte repetir eso como
argumento para justificar ante sus
tropas no ahora en el desfile del 9 de
mayo que celebra claro el fin de la
guerra en europa de la segunda guerra
mundial con la capitulación de alemania
a los rusos a la unión soviética el 9 de
mayo en 1945 entonces le dijo a las
tropas que sí que están luchando para
contraer un régimen yo nací pero también
les dijo
están luchando para garantizar la
seguridad de rusia porque la otan
pretende amiga aliada de ucrania
pretendía usar ucrania para invadir a
rusia totalmente falso y quiero repetir
una cosa porque hay algunos
comentaristas sobre todo como he visto
en deutsche welle la cadena alemana en
español sin que han estado diciendo como
que bueno que la culpa la tiene la otan
por la guerra porque se expandió bueno
porque se expandió la otan porque los
países que se han hecho miembros desde
la caída de la unión soviética
querían protección como esa fue la razón
de la creación de la otan en 1949
defender a europa de un ataque soviético
y claro la invasión de ucrania de ahora
y la del 2014
completamente y como decir justifica el
que países bálticos países bálticos
lituania letonia estonia
hungría república checa rumanía bulgaria
etcétera se hayan unido porque ahí se
puede ver los resultados con la agresión
rusa claro y ciertamente a eso le quería
preguntar entonces había una amenaza
porque rusia veía una amenaza de estos
países de la otan y occidente hacia su
territorio simplemente fue una bomba de
domo para para hacer esta invasión a
ucrania y realmente cuál es la finalidad
digamos hasta dónde quiere llegar rusia
con esta invasión solamente se quedaría
en el este en dan y ese lugar finalmente
quisiera agarrar a todo el país digamos
cómo puede proceder rusia militarmente
ahora en adelante si vamos a decir que
la oposición de rusia la otan es porque
la otan le impide a rusia recuperar el
control de territorios que fueron
históricamente del imperio ruso de los
zares después de la unión soviética y
putilo llegó a decir en 2021 que pues
con la caída de la unión soviética rusia
perdió territorios que por mil años
estuvo acumulando mentira porque el caso
de ucrania
acaso pues la inmensa mayoría de ucrania
de lo cree que era lituano polaca la
capturan pues a fines del siglo 18 pero
en todo caso es eso que local le impide
tragarse a los países que fueron parte
del imperio ruso sea zarista o soviético
segundo es pues qué es lo que quiere
rusia bueno quiere todo que tu cráneo
ciertamente todo ucrania
incluso llegaban a decir tras la
invasión del 24 de febrero en la prensa
estatal rusa como que ucrania no existía
también lo dijo putin que era un invento
de los bolcheviques de lenin antes había
dicho que era un invento de austro
hungría en en 2014 cuando se ocupa la
primera entonces no creen en la
existencia de ucrania como un
estado-nación así que idealmente para
vladimir putin sería quedarse con todo
cambia ahora al no poder porque la otan
se ha volcado en apoyar a ucrania y los
ucranianos luchan pues tratará de
quedarse con lo que pueda si si logra
retener crimea y los territorios del
este de ucrania y la costa del mar del
sureste de ucrania incluyendo mariupol
tratará de quedarse lo que pasa es que
claro selenski el gobierno ucraniano ha
dicho que van a intentar recuperar todo
lo que puedan y ahí está la cosa que más
bielorrusia estaría mi opinión en el
objetivo de putting eventualmente
incluso ha habido una tratado de unión
de rusia bielorrusia negociado el tiempo
de boris yeltsin en la década de los 90
moldavia o moldova también que si tiene
el enclave en transnistria y como cabeza
de puente al y los bálticos si llegar a
estallar una guerra con la otan tratarán
de quedarse con los países bálticos
lituania letonia estonia claro pues ya
nos quedan 30 segundos de conversación
profesor pero no quiero que sean que por
fuera pues una pregunta también del
millón porque lo ha afirmado gran y
también varios líderes occidentales
sobre todo europeos va a ucrania a ganar
esta guerra pudiera realmente ganar la
guerra contra rusia y que significaría
ganarla además
bueno yo pienso que con el apoyo de la
otan y que sigue en aumento con armas
más sofisticadas y con el apoyo de
información de inteligencia pueden ganar
la guerra porque las fuerzas
convencionales de tierra aéreas de los
rusos demostraron que no están a la
altura de la tecnología de la otan
occidental de eeuu y sus aliados que les
está haciendo suministrada a los
juzgaran ya no los ucranianos tiene
voluntad de seguir y ucrania va a ser de
la unión europea pienso que la otan está
combatiendo una guerra convencional no
declarada con rusia en ucrania y la otan
no va a permitir que rusia se recupere
militarmente o económicamente mientras
vladimir putin siga líder que es como un
adolfo hitler al que amenaza a los
países que fueron de la unión soviética
podría amenazar a georgia ya la
amenazaron hacer no irán a asia central
entonces que puede pasar bueno puede
haber una guerra nuclear en mi opinión
con vladimir putin en el poder al
sentirse de césped
de que está siendo derrotado pues
recurrir a eso las tropas ya no serían
tan útiles sería una política de
destrucción masiva más arriesgándose de
los europeos pero claro esperemos que no
sea así pero no le gusta la de finlandia
y suecia que quieran ser del otan y les
ha amenazado incluso con el uso de armas
nucleares